hello I'm understand your credit card so
you don't have to blue related pun I
don't know I just want get this review
over after thee and I can't believe in
saying this Smash Hits Smurfs movie it
only figure to do its sequel with the
exact same people
the downside is it's lame contrived not
funny pepper kids that for adults a for
any what actually let's make this easier
the oxide is it made a lot of money and
of course that's what matters most so
they threw more money at the sequel to
make more money back the result once
again is an unpleasant bouquet of nausea
under the guise of family entertainment
then seeing how the last time I did a
crossover was with the black nerd it
only figures to extend him the same
offer again hey black nerd how you
without homing in there put me down for
two hundred on the Patriots losing all
right ain't no way to ask your shoot
their way to victory this year
no obsessed when you gonna come back
here with my bone all right I got to get
hot man Black Canary has to review other
than Power Rangers movie trailer
I can't do that unless I get blade that
oh I am I must call you back there's a
white Walker present well well well if
it isn't a soldier bitch hi black nerd I
was reviewing smirch - and was one call
I get I get you thought I was only
beautiful sunny California the flooded
your neck of the woods in the dead of
winter sorry about a day of Neil Patrick
Harris Smurfs sequel with Joe punk-ass I
don't know about my ass is on quality
but I was wrong with you man
you think that's all there is to me you
think I'm all just Smurfs and Ninja
Turtles of power racism typhoon
affections and shit I don't know Oh
grown-ass man what about you you sit
around all day watching 80 to 90 kids TV
shows and movies I don't know that's
real sad I feel bad for you critic I'm
gonna pray for you maybe the next time
you do a charity shout out you should be
shouting out to get you a life
I got time for this I got an underground
gambling ring to take care
not to mention all those hot into no
switches on the seller ebay that fell
off a truck you ain't hear that from me
alright man please loser yeah that's
right you better run what'd you say
possibly nothing mm-hmm
watch yourself oh and by the way call me
when you do Smurf the last village
review I'll be right there for you Craig
I love you like a play cousin I'm outie
5000 change ow yelps your punk-ass
mother well I'll show him we got a life
I'm reviewing some arts - but Sam opens
with summer ology is not the church Tom
Cruise belongs to the evil wizard
Gargamel was concocting a diabolical
climb definitely the same church as the
narrator gives the backstory of how
their only female Smurfette entered
their group at the creation of Gargamel
to infiltrate them Papa saw the good in
her he turned her into a true-blue Smurf
what did he do her in there is the same
treatment linked yes when he goes into
that woman's house to regain life
because it's Oh this'll be more than a
PG but it seems like she still may have
a little bit of evil in her he's got a
dragon
oh it was all just a bad movie Smurfette
are you okay I heard you from my peaking
perch outside your window there
everything's going to be fine now I'm
sure you were going to take a shower
something so why don't you get to that
gnorga mania the magical sensation that
has captivated the nation the movie
kindly reminds us that Entertainment
Tonight is still on TV and the dark Mel
uses what little magic he has left to
become a famous magician this pleases
his bad meow mix commercial I mean pet
cat these two characters are vex Ian
Hackett plays like Christina Ricci and
JB Smoove I've been treating them to you
because the movie forgot we didn't see
the maid we know nothing about them
we're just stuck with these two
characters that never ever got an
introduction don't you hate it when that
happens bill mm-hmm
so bill but there's big trouble brewing
down at summer village like Summerfest
thinks everyone forgot her birthday when
really there's a surprise party being
planned it's getting real occasionally
it's good to have a little alone time
yes okay guy yeah we don't even here
we're good oh no okay it's like a
billion of you and nobody invented
Facebook yet I think this would be quite
common also he nearly wiped out their
village you're lucky they didn't burn
you like a Kentucky Fried Jonah Marge
and you're bitching that they forgot
your birthday privilege was the thing
you've been a Violet Beauregarde on it
begin a blue that's the cruel name given
by parents Neil Patrick Harris and Jayma
Mays celebrating his birthday with the
arrival of Harris's stepdad but Harris
hates him because he's reasonably nice
Neela Soviets friends which makes you my
friends are all good hey you'll wanted
to run off like this nothing like the
embrace of too proud Doyle men
and not a Doyle man no you're the rough
draft of Niles crane regardless we have
to hate each other for some reason and I
still don't really see a reason I'm
going to pretend to each and every one
of you with a free corndog
oh no he accidentally gave someone
allergic to peanuts a peanut product
okay
now he's a bastard we sympathize with
Harris who shows up and ruins things
that's what he does you hand out treats
hugs and complimented how were they long
so Gargamel says he wants to kidnap
summer fat to figure out how he can make
blue Smurf so he can steal their magical
essence to take over the world and then
the entire world shall bow before me
like I have a leak there he used to be
he wanted to eat them then you want to
turn them into gold and he wanted to
increase his magic now he wants to
conquer the world Jesus he's gonna run
out think he wants to do soon the entire
world shall bow before me and after that
I'll take up skydiving I don't know just
making this up as I go so he opens the
doorway to Smurf Village through that
you've never seen this a portal in the
skies I've literally done so many of
these jokes I have a punch card for a
free sub oh thank you and he says BEC
see you to kidnap Smurfette another sign
of high-paid writing there and then she
said so long yeah not bad for zona just
learned how to talk my powers of
deduction lead me to believe that this
is the work of Gargamel yeah who else
would be you show no other characters
are part of your world
so while Papa assembles a team to go and
save her Harris is dealing with real
troubles of his own like you stepped in
wants to put a crown on the birthday boy
I what you didn't bring the crime it'll
put the crown on him
this is the way you do it look you see
what's going on out there oh yeah he's a
terrific role model well this is
excusable what kind of monster what done
such a thing
hey rose wrong with you uh well after
being estranged from my drunk abusive
grandpa for years he calls me up today
and told me that even at birth she
didn't consider me part of the family oh
come on
that's nothing this grandparent gave his
grandchild I'll pay for half a paper hat
so we also find out that he he also gave
away Harris's bird when he was younger
because the stepdad was allergic when my
dad took off he loves to use and I loved
that bird all the more reason to hate
the bastard worth authority figure ever
for the corner opens up and the first
return to take credibility away from
Harris once more welcome to hell this is
exactly what awaits you in the fiery pit
it's just this on a non-stop loop that
you Oh am I kidding any part of this
movie would be playing an L what are you
guys doing here
Smurfette's been taken wait what hate
waiting take it what other way can you
interpret that you got can't see Liam
Neeson movie what any what do you mean
I'll call the dog cleaner you get blue
spot for Joe Harrison and family agreed
to help them by going to France to find
out where dargah Mel is performing and
Bill no I don't know you were here mmm
God seeing you again makes me realize I
should forgive him for the bad things he
said hmm thank you Bill mm-hmm I'm so
glad we have this detailed history
together
Teddy so bill
Sheila tries to find out what room
Gargamel is in but the hotel won't let
her what she dresses up like Audrey
Hepburn so I will tell her no one wants
to be on that did you talk oh I'm just
astonished there's a breakfast at
tiffany's so much and yet no Mickey
Rooney dress up imagine how that would
have gone oh hell no I'm not doing a
sketch on and I want to keep this
channel oh yeah I forgot
blues performance and this is well he's
a kid so how do I put it lightly is the
worst thing I've ever seen after every
moment you'd swear he screams yeah I
said a line my god
[Music]
anyhow I'm losing yeah are you an angel
oh sorry no Jay Chloe well it's hard to
tell the difference wasn't it Stark
Amell uses his magic to turn Harris's
father into a duck that's flying Harris
around the room you're not acting you're
not acting that out yes but why does it
ya know throw the kid in there I'll be
more than worth the price of admission
what is cross about always barge in and
ruin everything
what a walking disaster I should know I
really hope someone was just channel
surfing and came across this scene I
would love for them to rationalize
what's going on which is I'm pleased yes
the source the fan the eyes and say that
I can't that's right because it's not
and yes by the way a good chunk of this
movie we have to feel with the stepdad
as a duck okay I need to know if you fit
in a blender well makes the scene even
stranger is that he's got a little black
stripe on his beak so it looks like
we're listening to Hitler duck I do not
want to listen to Hitler duck
no wonder the cartoons that preceded it
was this of course just adds to Harris's
anger of his stepdad I'm gonna strangle
that duck mix like a black cloud that
follows me around shows that what do you
want them to or not a lot of fun is done
you can do that he's not my father
need I remind you paper hasn't being
allergic to birds and devil whoa oh my
god every time that kid talks cancer
gets a little stronger but that doesn't
stop his death there from coming anyway
and getting caught by the chef's Jack
it's time to piss off so nobody face
really duck Hitler just made that joke
what's the next house flipper a literal
goose tub it looks like summer fed is
getting more friendly with vixy but
unfortunately they are use their IQ to
smurf joke in the last movie
sorry Papa Smurf didn't come for you and
I'm sorry you were in that darn cat
maybe your place is here with us yeah
maybe it is yes after being here less
than a day again most of the day being
used to torture you clearly this is
where you belong
why is she being nice to love you just
identifying with the captor no she
thinks we don't care anymore maybe it
has something to do with us acting like
we didn't care anymore
yeah you know her sensitivity was so
great like she clearly said here they
know how tough my birthday can be why
would you be stupid enough to fake her
out is that like half a day telling
someone how much you hate them and that
the last manager thing kidding
love you man again maybe that would work
seeing how she suddenly thinks dargah
mel is a caring father simply because he
gives her a gift
yeah well okay I'm not going to say
anything but I am going to freeze frame
here do as you will Internet it's the
Smurfs nobody will fault you Smurfette
also seems to get her first taste of
real power when Gargamel gives her a
tiny magic wand how do you know I won't
use it on you right because because I am
your father
search your feelings you know it to be
true
well at least he didn't do that minute
you kind of like seeing her go a little
sadistic now that you can and you will
know my name is the law but I lay my
vengeance upon thee she seems to enjoy
doing evil especially when it's
inconsistent like not breaking mirror
glass but breaking window glass and
simmer firm one stop while heresies to
step in hatred of time
Rissa free of love what do you Martin
Luther Wing but then with the star was
related it just feels good okay
Harris's dad catches the falling Smurfs
just before he turns back into a human
where's Smurfette nice going
you were sitting painted with clansmen
mustard how dare you save us from Earth
from a falling building actually I would
hate him to
you
a couple of your buddy Walter Benedict
here from awesome comics and I'm here
with Iowa in Frankfort and this week
we're talking about Game of Thrones
season 6 if it's the best season yet
we're going to answer that question on
awesome Comics this week so go ahead and
check out that episode
so let's reveal that all appearances
anger towards the stepdad was for
nothing
Oh not because Harris was being a total
heartless dick but because the bird that
was taken away from him as a kid wasn't
because the stepdad was allergic
but because Harris was allergic mother
and I both knew that break your heart to
think the part had to go away because of
you it's my father's but Tuesday isn't
well that changes what was obviously a
legit reason to hate a parent well
that's almost as dumb as hating your
family because they forgot to throw you
a birthday party what do you think
what's the first take I mean if they
always have to use the best take for the
film what do you think the other takes
were get back Dexter get back he
prepares a packet ha ha ha ha you know
if I take 43 I'd give up too and because
the film totally doesn't care that it
wants the main theme to be daddy issues
exactly like the last film we once again
have another balcony scene between
Harris and Papa Smurf exactly the same
as the first one I haven't done enough
Gargamel just made her but you you made
her what she is no one asked you to you
just did that's a pretty special kind of
love well still hate my dad opted to
botch this movie so bad they'll reboot
it in a few years
Oh Gargamel finally shows us true colors
and tells Murphy that if she doesn't
give the secret formula to changing the
Smurfs Blue Hill at vexy and Hackett
died not seeing the downside here I'll
give it to you
back when hopeful but a dab of royal
jelly what since grade plutonium I'd say
unicorns euro a Smurfs movie with
glowing reviews now you're playing with
me the formula works and he puts them in
an evil machine to suck the life out of
them to gain their essence
hey this might be a happy ending after
all well there she is
Oh gays Gargamel's of formula but he
saved our lives
so that's two stupid things you did I so
get on you but they all get captured and
soon Gargamel and taking all their
essence away Oh what no onions it's
still not over that what was that about
but Harrison is stepdad reunite and
destroy the evil machine resulting in
I'll give credit a very pretty vision
even shit could accidently were
beautiful sometimes and the perps are
safe once again
is this what happy feels like no no if
it's in the filmy it's not what happy
feels like yeah yeah yeah
yes don't expect to be nominated for a
Screen Actors in anytime soon
that they grow up so fast
but that money tomorrow's movies do they
take great talent and use them at their
work Neil Patrick Harris
so for unlikable in this none of the
actors are given any funny lines even
Hank Azaria whose voice is pretty funny
and has good timing still can't make any
of this work it's a bad follow-up to an
already bad bill and I'm happy as hell
it's the last one I ever have to watch
force equal money I'm going to crack it
thank god it's finally over you can't
just do two sequels force equal marks oh
really let me get my rule book that
doesn't exist oh yeah here it is right
under Article one okay the people
deserve more even if it goes beyond the
month yeah what am I getting it oh come
on bill don't give me that look
I know what you're insinuating
especially after all we've been through
hmm okay fine I'll do one more only for
you bill hmm bill wonderful he is I love
you bill
mm-hmm after next week there will be one
more sequel review Oh which one oh
you'll see
okay bill what the hell I found a new
[Music]
hey the Walker here doing the charity
shout out and this week we are doing the
African wildlife organization this
charity works to ensure that wildlife
and wild lands of Africa will endure
forever protecting an astounding
diversity of species including human
beings Africa is home to certain species
that are facing extinction by pointing
safeguards in place like training
Rangers using sniffer dogs and
empowering community they're helping to
ensure all of Africa's wildlife survive
critical to protecting Africa's wildlife
are the local people sharing the land
often alongside each other can lead to
struggles and resources and
deforestation if people in wildlife
learn to live together inside and
outside of protected areas the future
for all will thrive if you go to their
site or look at their YouTube videos you
can see all the terrible things that are
being done to some of these animals by
poachers and other poor choices however
you can also see all the animals who are
being saved and will continue to be
saved
thanks to your help these are very
important creatures in a very important
place and they need to be saved
take a look at these incredible animals
and see how you can save an entire
species from extinction
you